[Musique]
bonsoir
à quoi est ce qu'on pense quand on
entend palais de l'univers
et il a fini où est il des limites
quand j'étais petit
je t'ai toujours pas signer à tout ce
qui concerne l'univers à savoir sa
formation ces différentes constitutions
et la principale question que je me
posais était
comme la vie est elle apparue sur terre
à l'époque je pensais qu'il y avait des
réponses exactes à toutes ces questions
mais je n'arrive tout simplement pas à
les avoir étant donné que l'astronomie
était un dom maintenant connue au
burkina
et donc plus tard je suis arrivé à
l'université
du vin se doit d'adopter
de fait la physique pour pouvoir devenir
plus tard ingénieur en génie civil
et c'est là
et je te confronter à des propos du
géant
la physique est trop compliqué pour une
femme
et que ça sera difficile pour toi de ta
sortie là dedans
et que même je restais de devenir folle
par la suite
étant donné que j'étais déjà déterminé
je me suis pas laissé influencer par ces
propos
et donc j'ai poursuivi mon paquereau
universités anormal le compas me l'a dit
quand je suis arrivé à ma maîtrise
l'astronomie venait d'être intégré au
bukina comme matières optionnelles en
physique et j'ai donc pas hésité à
suivre locaux qui étaient diffusés
dispensé plus tôt par le professeur
claude carignan qui cherchent un
astronome qui venaient du québec
je vous assure que j'ai tout était et
bruit parce que j'avais appris dans le
coup et c'est là que j'ai découvert que
notre connaissance de l'univers
était encore jeune
et évoluer avec le temps
[Musique]
par exemple
c'est au début du 20e siècle les
astronomes pensaient que l'univers se
limitait à notre galaxie la voie lactée
au delà de laquelle il n'y avait plus
rien tout s'arrêter là il pensait aussi
que l'univers était statique c'est à
dire immuable tu ne changes pas donc
c'est l'histoire d'un repas du soir que
dans la patine pas la même chose pour le
présent ainsi que le futur
donc c'est dans les années
quant aux astronomes américains d'une
onde et d'huile un bol en observant le
ciel avec un côté les scop découvre des
galaxies au delà de la voie lactée
et c'est pas tout il va aussi le maillot
qui se régalent à tout cela est bien
plus vite les unes les autres qu'elles
sont loin dans l'espace
cela veut dire tout simplement que les
galactiques était plus loin c'est loyen
davantage plus vite que celles qui
étaient plus proches il va donc conclu
que l'univers est loin d'être statique
mais serait plutôt un ex passion et
cette découverte va révolutionner le
monde de la science est peint métal de
couvent est dominé à d'autres galaxies
par la suite
mais à quoi ressemble une galaxie
cette image
est l'image de notre galaxie la voie
lactée
je pourrais du poil
c'est le système solaire c'est à dire
notre place dans la galaxie
je parle de système solaire je fais
allusion au soleil notre planète terre
et les autres planètes
donc le système solaire ici il la situe
à 30 ans à les lumières du centre de la
galaxie
mais c'est quoi une année lumière une
année lumière c'est la distance
parcourue par la lumière en une année
pareil
quand on prend le soleil il est situé à
8 minutes lumière seule la lumière par
huit minutes du soleil pour nous atteint
sutter donc lorsque nous observons le
soleil nous le voyons pas tel qu'il est
maintenant mais tel qu'il était il ya
huit minutes
et cette galaxie que nous voyons là
elles contiennent des centaines de
milliards des toiles comme le soleil
et notre soleil c'est une étoile de
taille moyenne
et si nous voulons représenter la taille
du soleil par rapport à la terre
voilà à quoi ça ressemble
là
on voit que la terre est plus petit
rapport au soleil un thème de taille le
soleil fait plus de 100 voire la tête de
la taille et de la terre
est notre galaxie quant à elles
contiennent des centaines de milliards
des toiles comme le soleil donc une
galati c'est gigantesque
si vous prenez le soleil comme un point
comme cela
notre galaxie elle n aura plus de 35
fois la taille du bukina faso
cgm et l'univers observable quant à elle
contient des centaines de milliards de
galaxies
c'est énorme
l'univers est gigantesque
mais détrompez vous
cela ne représente plus qu'un film pâtit
de l'univers
le satellite main la c1
2009 nous a permis de tracer les
différents au soutien de l'univers
à savoir 5 ou sein de l'univers serait
constitué de composantes visible c'est à
dire des composantes constitué de
protons neutrons et d'électro
comme j'avais mentionné précédemment je
parlais de galaxies des toiles de
planète donc tout cela représente
l'univers visible elle représente 5 %
les 95 % restants elle composait de
composante invisible
qui serait reparti
là il n'y a pas de proposition mais
serait reparti environ 24 % de matière
noire et 60 11 %
d'énergie sombre
on voit maintenant à l'étape elle
composante invisible tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations concernant cette
composante du qu'on n'arrive pas à les
observer on voit maintenant que pour
comprendre la formation et l'évolution
de notre univers il serait très
intéressant de comprendre les
composantes invisible de notre univers
et tout cela m'a donné une motivation
pour continuer dans la recherche en
devenant une tâche et recherche en
astrophysique donc après ma maîtrise
j'ai décidé de faire un deuil a un
physique appliquée parce qu'il n'ya pas
de 2 à d'astrophysique au bukina mène à
la possibilité pana son deuil à deux
choisi comme option de recherche
astrophysique et c'est ce que j'ai pas
hésité de faire mais mon entourage
n'a pas compris mon choix de perm
enrichi en astrophysique par selon eux
c'est une perte de temps ça ne va rien
m'apporter étudiait les objets de
l'univers ne m'apportera pas grand chose
vu que toutes les ressources se trouvent
super
et j'ai la chance d'avoir deux parents
sont compréhensifs et qui m'ont toujours
soutenu dans mes choix donc quand je
leur ai expliqué mon cas que je voulais
continuer dans la recherche en tant que
astrophysiciens ils m'ont dit si ça te
plaît pourquoi pas l'unss doit
donc après manque de ja
j'ai eu la chance d'obtenir une bourse
pour continuer mes études en france
précisément au laboratoire
d'astrophysique de marseille où je
travaille avec le professeur philippe
braem et le professeur claude carignan
et quand je suis arrivé à marseille
je me suis d'abord familiariser au moins
de la recherche en participant à des
missions utilisant le cloud télescope en
apprenant à réduire et analyser les
données
la chance m'a souri une deuxième point
parce que j'ai eu la chance d'obtenir un
financement de l'université de cape town
en afrique du sud et cela allait me
permettre d'effectuer ma recherche
incluent les deux instituts c'est à dire
le laboratoire d'astrophysique de
marseille et l'université de cape town
maintenant pour ce qui concerne mon
sujet de thèse de doctorat
comme j'avais entendu parler de la
matière sombre de l'univers
qui représentait environ 24% de
l'univers et dans sa présence sa
connaissance pourrait contribuer à mieux
connaître l'origine de l'univers ainsi
que l'origine de la terre j'ai opté de
faire marcher sur cette matière dont
poum au sujet de thèse
j'ai décidé de travailler sur la
distribution de la matière noire à
l'intérieur des galaxies
il soit de la matière noire a commencé
dans les années 1930 3
lorsqu un astronome suisse du nom de
fuite j'écris un étudiant le mouvement
légaliste à l'intérieur d'un amant
découvre que les galaxies tout n'est
plus vite qu'elle le devrait et cela
n'est pas dû à la présence de matière
visible dans la main quand je parle de
matière visible je fais allusion aux
protons neutrons
électrons tout ce qui constitue les
galaxies les planètes et nous tous ici
dans cette salle
et donc
il va conclure
que le fait que les galactiques tournait
vite à l'intérieur de la main cela est
dû à une présence de matière invisible
mais sa découverte n'a pas été prise au
sérieux pourquoi s'il n'était pas une
bonne collaboration avec son équipe à
l'époque sentait n'est pas du tout il a
fallu attendre trente ans plus tard
c'est à dire dans les années 1970 pour
qu'une scientifique américaine du nom de
vieira rubine en étudiant la coupe de
rotation d'une galaxie
découvre que les galaxies
les objets situés à l'extrémité des
galaxies tout n'est plus vite que ceux
qui étaient situés au centre
sa découverte n'entre pas en vigueur
avec la loi de newton puisque la loi de
newton prédit que plus un objet est
proche du centre plus il tourne plus
vite
si nous prenons le cas du système
solaire
mercure ou peut-être la planète terre
qui est plus proche du soleil tourne
plus vite que jupiter par exemple que
plus de loyer
donc vers have a conclu le destin d'une
matière invisible
qui serait à l'origine
de ce fait
c'est maintenant que les astronomes
pompe panne les essences de la matière
noire au sérieux
pourquoi matière noire
tout simplement parce qu' elle n'est pas
détectable on n'arrive pas à l'observer
néanmoins on peut l'étudier
mais
comme on a étudié une matière si on
n'arrive pas à la détecter
lorsqu'on observe des objets lointains
contenant une grande quantité de matière
noire
par exemple les galaxy où des amas de
galaxies on observe une déformation des
objets qui se trouvent à l'arrière plan
et cela est dû au fait que la matière
noire de vie la trajectoire de la
lumière mais cela est appelée lentille
gravitationnelle
et les lentilles gravitationnelles
permet de déterminer la quantité exacte
de matière noire dans l'espace et la
façon dont elle est distribuée
je vais prendre un exemple banal
lorsque vous mettez une pièce dans une
grand récipient d'eau et que vous
observez la pièce el al est déformé
cela est dû au fait que la trajectoire
suivie par la lumière est déformé par
l'eau avant d'atteindre notre oeil ici
le temps est en quelque sorte un visez
donc elle joue le rôle de matière noire
c'est ce qu'on observe
lorsqu'on observe des objets qui
traverse une grande quantité de matière
noire parce qu'elle joue la matière
noire des fon la trajectoire de la
lumière qui la traversent on peut aussi
déterminer
la distribution de la matière noire à
l'intérieur des galaxies comme la paix
tu verras rubine
en utilisant la vitesse de rotation de
la galaxie en fonction
du rayon
par exemple si cette image
l'approuvent est
représente la coupe de rotation de la
galaxie et la cour jaune ce celle de la
matière visible vous voyez bien que la
cour john ne décrit pas la courbe est
dans la galaxie dont il faut inclure une
autre matière et cette matière on
n'arrive pas à l'observer non c'est la
matière noire
et ça c'est mon travail de
doctorat
c'est un travail de plaisir donc
qu'est ce que je fais j'utilise
plusieurs méthodes pour déterminer la
distribution de la matière noire à
l'intérieur des galaxies et le but c'est
de trouver une méthode standard qui
pourrait être utilisé pour déterminer le
comportement de la matière noire dans
toutes les galaxies et c'est mon équipe
et moi avons trouvé ce cas présent ce
qu'il y a pas un modèle qui a lu cieux
en bloc toutes les galaxies étant donné
que les gars là s'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes propriétés c'est un peu comme les
humains et allez petit il ya des grands
et à des vieux il ya des jeunes les
jeunes passent
maintenant dans le domaine de la
recherche
je ne cherche plus à avoir des
certitudes sur les questions concernant
l'origine de l'univers l origine de la
terre ah je vois à tel point notre
univers le gauche un quad un mystère qui
reste à être élucidé
une bonne nouvelle
le bookeen à ce qu'il ya un projet
d'installation d'un télescope de
recherche et une équipe
[Applaudissements]
est une équipe d'astronomes information
est donc dans les années à venir le
burkina pourrait contribuer à élucider
ce mystère de l'univers et peut-être
apporter une connaissance quant à
l'origine de notre univers ainsi que de
notre planète terre
j'aimerais finir par lasser un message
pour mes jeunes joueurs
j'aimerais dire quand vous avez des
ambitions et que vous avez quelque chose
qui vous tient à coeur que vous voulez
réaliser de ne pas vous laisser
influencer par votre entourage et même
souvent par la société je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]